arthritis is very common degenerative
disease it is certainly not genetically
transmitted in any way shape or form I'd
say ninety percent of arthritis begins
as osteopenia osteoporosis
osteoarthritis do gender by arthritis
and really gets bad when you get to the
bone to bone arthritis point there is a
secondary type of arthritis called
rheumatoid arthritis which is an
infection with a bug called mycoplasma
you can cure a root arthritis in two
weeks with a antibiotic called
minocycline kills the bug very quickly
and then you do have the residual damage
in the residual damage of rheumatoid
arthritis and the other forms of
degenerative arthritis I like to use the
healthy bone and joint pack all 90
essential nutrients 60 mineral 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids 30
cents of fatty acids there's a special
emphasis on what we called Luca gel is
part of the healthy bone and joint pack
and for an average adult I like 15 a day
five at breakfast lunch and dinner and
that's designed to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone matrix
and bone itself